[Applaus]
[Musik]
was waren die Aufzeichnungen meiner
Mutter die verhängnisvolle Wanderung
vorkapasshöhe Oberwald
meistens
will ich das Verbrechen passiert also
ich mag mir nicht vorstellen dass meine
Mutter in ein fremdes Auto gestiegen ist
und mit irgendjemandem irgendwo
hingefahren ist der See was Böses
angetan hat
nicht abschließen für mich und meine
Familie hat es am Ende kein Unterschied
gemacht also wir tragen genauso
wahrscheinlich
ja genau Eis Bild von meiner Mutter
schwarz weiß
gefangen
das darf einfach nicht passieren
[Musik]
der Jugend und es Bedürfnis meine
richtige Mutter zu finden ist der
Jugendzeit gestiegen ich glaube mir wird
wie meine Mutter hat man einfach quält
und dadurch
Facebook Post gemacht mit dem Kollegen
die Suche richtig stark
[Musik]
nach langjähriger Suche ohne einen
Erfolg zu erringen richtig mich nun an
euch ich suche meine leiblichen Eltern
Familien
Mutter Gina vermisst seit Februar 2000
und dass sie das dass sie da zum Arzt in
Zürich klappt hat
und dass wir also dass man nicht weiß wo
sie ist
ich bitte darum teilt diesen Beitrag
denn ich möchte nun endlich wissen woher
ich komme und ich habe Sehnsucht nach
einer Familie
[Musik]
passiert und ob das jetzt verbracht
ziemlich überraschend ist es
ziemlich schnell gegangen mit ganz
vielen
[Musik]
ex-manner
und dann haben wir schlussendliche der
Wohnung
wie nennt man das wenn man das
[Musik]
ganz viel Medien sind
und dadurch
will einfach wissen was vor 19 Jahren
passiert ist Suche nach Eltern mit so
vielen Reaktionen habe ich wirklich
nicht gerechnet wo bist du Mutter
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen im Nachtcafé
Marco Hauenstein auch sie hatten keinen
leichten Start ins lebenden bereits als
Baby mussten sie einen mehrwöchigen
heroinenzug hinter sich bringen ihre
Mutter war Drogenabhängig sie sind in
der Schweiz groß geworden bei
Pflegeeltern ihre Mutter haben sie
gesehen als sie ein Baby waren ihren
Vater kennen sie gar nicht
als Baby und sind sie erst einmal in den
Entzug gekommen weil ihre Mutter Heroin
süchtig war wie sehr waren sie
eigentlich davon auch körperlich
betroffen dann wie lange hat das
angedauert
also das Spiel ich heute noch ich bin
auf einem Auge blind und das wird auch
von dem Heroin kommen von früher aber
ich gehe gut mit dem um
Schicksal vom 19-Jährigen Marco berührt
sehr für die Mannschaft ich glaube daran
und ja es wäre natürlich schön wenn man
sie wirklich findet
ja ich nicht Überforderung und trotzdem
meine glückwunsch
sehr gut
[Musik]
die meine Tochter im Kindergarten in der
ersten Woche nach dem Verschwinden
meiner Mutter angefertigt hat
wahrscheinlich das so wie Kinder so
etwas dann für sich verarbeiten
[Musik]
Sohn
das ist sie am 14 september
2002 am Morgen an Nina das mir die malte
keine
[Musik]
stellen
circa zahlen ist immer mit dem
Helikopter gestartet und prüfen das
Gebiet Tricks
im ersten Moment sehr gut die
Bedingungen
und dann ist
mir so aufgrund von Nachtisch
pro Jahr verschwinden in der Schweiz
rund 5000 Personen etwa 80% tauchen bald
wieder auf andere bleiben verschwunden
wird jemand nach ein bis zwei Monaten
nicht gefunden registrieren viele
Kantone diese Personen als sogenannt
Langzeit vermisste gemäss Aussagen der
kantonalen polizeikurs gegenüber SRF dog
gibt es in der Schweiz derzeit rund
1.100 Langzeit vermisste
[Musik]
ich bin bereitschaftsstation
wenn im Hochgebirge oder irgendeinem
unwegsamer Glanz am Unfall passiert ist
oder der Personen vermisst warten
um den die Sache zu erledigen
dann sind wir Prüfung
das ist der nicht Erfolg Siemer in den
superfernsehen alles mögliche aber die
vermisst die Frauen nicht gefunden
wir waren zu der Zeit im Urlaub auf
Fuerteventura
ich war an dem Tag mit meiner Tochter zu
einem Fotoshooting am Strand verabredet
und ich hatte dann gesehen im Zimmer
aber Blick auf das Handy dass
meine Mutter mich angerufen hatte
mehrfach 2-3 mal
und bevor wir dann zum Essen gegangen
sind habe ich gesagt geht ihr schon mal
vor ich rufe es mal Mama an und frage
was los ist mit der Grund haben warum es
mich angerufen hat und dann ging mal ein
Stiefvater ans Telefon und er berichtete
mit dann kurz dass meine Mutter seit
gestern verschwunden sei
in jedem
falls du voll in all die richtige
ermittelt
[Musik]
es geht darum dass man die Persona
WhatsApp mit der verschwunden oder der
vermisst du Person sind samt sie das
motivinformationen
aus erster Hand ziemlich Hund spring ins
gut Karl Wilhelm Walter sie werden im
Rahmen der polizeilichen Ermittlung
aufgrund ihrer gestrigen
Vermisstenanzeige Ihrer Frau spring ins
gut Ingeborg in Oberwald als
Auskunftsperson einvernommen wie stellen
Sie sich dazu ich nehme davon Kenntnis
seit wann kommen sie nach Oberwald in
die Ferien
schon das 14 mal meine Frau Ingeborg war
zum 15 mal hier sie war immer im Chalet
Claudia so wie jetzt auch
wenn mir ein befriedigt durch fairer
geht es zum einen
Informationen als Beispiel wenn jemand
mir das Ehepaar springen gut zu Postauto
hat genug was hatten sie am Dienstag
14.09.2010 beabsichtigt wir sind mit dem
Postbus auf die furkapasshöhe
zeitlich gesehen sollte er um 12:30 Uhr
losfahren hat er aber Verspätung
um 14 Uhr machten wir uns zu Fuß von der
furkapasshöhe in Richtung Oberwald
Einweg geht am Berg lang ziemlich auf
gleicher Höhe dieser Weg ist nicht groß
anstrengend
er wird dann steiniger und geht zweimal
durch einen Tunnel dann kommt man an
eine Verzweigung da steht auf einem
Schild Oberwald
[Musik]
wir sind dann bis zum Gipfelkreuz
hochgelaufen von dem Kreuz kann man
schon runter nach Oberwald sehen
da ist die obersten
meiner Frau gefiel diese Weg nicht mehr
meine Frau blieb dann dort stehen und
ich wollte mich in nähere Umgebung nach
einem geeigneten Wanderweg umsehen
da ich keinen Weg gefunden habe ging ich
wieder zurück als ich sie nicht mehr
gesehen habe habe ich laut nach ihr
gerufen so laut ich konnte rief ich
ingeburg
ich bin dann am
Mittwochabend im Zürich angekommen habe
mir dann Auto gemietet und bin dann
abends spät nach Oberwald gefahren bin
dann auf der furkerpasshöhe es war
dunkel es war ungefähr 24 Uhr 23 24 Uhr
auf der furkerpasshöhe war und da habe
ich aufs Thermometer geschaut und da
habe ich gesehen
haben -1 - 2 Grad und da war mir
eigentlich schon klar dass das jetzt
irgendwie wird also das konnte meine
Mutter zwei Nächte drei Nächte bei den
Temperaturen ohne eine Jacke ohne Tee
ohne irgendwie Medikamente eigentlich
nichts wirklich überleben
sage ich so im Herzen ich glaube
sie ist noch irgendwo
[Musik]
bitte
zwischen 1986 und 2007 sind 10 Frauen
vom Zürcher Drogenstrich verschwunden
verurteilt
wir sind diese Wachter und Christina
brandtaschen
[Musik]
Aargau und dann bin ich später in Zürich
Monika
[Musik]
und
ja sie haben also das weiß er ob sie
und ich glaube wenn sie wenn ich rede
jetzt nicht so viel bedeutet hätte
wäre
und dann mit 60 bin ich zur
Pflegefamilie hoch und dann sind wir da
auf das wunderschön
schnell erfahren dass es nicht Mini
richtige Familie ist also dass ich
wieder Pflegefamilie wohne und
ja es ist Geheimnisse also es sind immer
sehr offen sind direkt also das ist
jetzt früher gewesen
[Musik]
sie ist eines Nachts offenbar noch etwas
passiert ist
psychischen Problemen
Option
das Leben
alles zurück klar
es geht für mehr wie zwei Theorie wo
Baby gangbasi also einerseits der Suizid
aber für mich geht
die Kantonspolizei in unterteilen
langzeitvermisste meist in folgende
Kategorien untergetaucht Unfall Suizid
Delikt
[Musik]
nur bei einem kleinen Prozentsatz
handelt es sich um mutmaßlich ungelöste
Kriminalfälle sogenannte cold cases
ein Delikt kann bei vermissten
allerdings grundsätzlich nie
ausgeschlossen werden
[Musik]
wenn man sich anschaut
wie viele Verbrechen geschehen und wo
dann sozusagen der Täter im
unmittelbaren Umfeld zu finden ist dann
ist das das natürlichste was man erst
einmal fragt
[Musik]
gestern als sie sich beim Hungerberg
trennten gab es vorgängig einen Streit
nein nichts die Stimmung zwischen uns
war normal meistens gebe ich ja nach
Politik sucht die objektive Wahrheit und
solche Kredit aufgefühle oder durch
Gefühle vor jemand
wie war ihre Frau ausgerüstet gewesen
sie hatte hohe Wanderschuhe und einen
roten Pullover sie trug zwei
Fotoapparate mit sich Medikamente hatte
sie keine mit sie musste solche morgens
mittags und abends einnehmen
Ingeborg musste eine seebrille tragen
auch gestern hat sie eine Brille
getragen ansonsten hatte sie nichts mit
haben sie ihre Erklärung etwas
beizufügen oder abzuändern nein
[Musik]
sehr herzliche Beziehung liebevolle
Beziehung
ich würde sagen traumhaft also das
hatten sich zwei gefunden die irgendwie
gut zueinander passten die aufeinander
aufgepasst haben die meine Mutter
sicherlich eher die starke
Persönlichkeit die auch den Ton
angegeben hat
und man Stiefvater der meiner Mutter
jeden Wunsch von den Augen abgelesen hat
alles gemacht hat also ich könnte mir
überhaupt nicht vorstellen dass er
irgendwas mal verneint hätte gesagt
hätte nein das mache ich nicht oder
selbst dann wenn sie vielleicht nicht so
recht wollen unangenehm war hätte es
trotzdem gemacht dass man Stiefvater
etwas damit zu tun haben könnte ist für
uns undenkbar gewesen und ist es auch
heute noch es passt nicht zu ihm es
passt nicht zu der gesamten Situation zu
der Lebenssituation es
gab es gab kein Motiv ganz im Gegenteil
er war froh nach dem Tod der ersten Frau
eine zweite Frau zu finden oder zu haben
das macht dich nicht
auf dem Standpunkt
durch die Nachrichten durchgegangen aber
ich bin halt nicht mit also mit weder
mit Antwort
Weg ist wo man gerne mit dem Mensch
passiert ist das ist
furchtbare Vorstellung
es ist ein spannender Fall und ich in
Kärnten
aktiv hat mir abote das osterfrei jetzt
so
machen
natürlich ganz andere Möglichkeiten
durch den Detektiv gesehen dass man ihn
noch Fragen haben verschiedene
gefunden wie groß muss
das gar nicht möglich sie wurden ruhig
und unter volksschildert hat
wo man relativ schnell zum Ziel bei der
Kurs
sind lokalisieren man hat dann
festgestellt dass existierte Vermissten
für
Informationen über Minimum Mutter und du
den Druck von der Medien
es ist schlussendlich
dann zu hoch dass
die Polizei und auch Behörde deine
Informationen unser Glück haben also
ohne wer da nicht möglich sein
[Musik]
und Polizei hat sich dann bei mir
persönlich gemacht und hat mir
vorgeladen für alles Gespräch wir haben
Telefon schon
wissen was es gab mit den schwierigen
Nachrichten am Telefon überbringen das
machen wir immer persönlich
[Musik]
ich bin tätig als Projektmanager für
internationale große
Bauprojekte im Wesentlichen touristische
Projekte
Hotels Marina Skigebiete Golfanlagen und
das ist eine zeitintensive Tätigkeit
aber auch an die sehr viel Spaß macht
[Musik]
das war eine intensive Zeit klar weil es
sozusagen ein eigenes Projekt noch
nebenbei war was man so nebenbei noch
mit erledigen musste mit all denen
Abstimmungen mit all den Fragen die alle
möglichen Leute auch dazu haben
berechtigterweise Freunde Bekannte
meiner Mutter
mit der Suche ging es dann so weiter
dass an dem Morgen nachdem ich
angekommen war entschieden wurde dass
man zur weiteren Suche sogenannte
gebirgsflächen Suchende einsetzen wollte
gebirgsflagge Wirkung ist mir sehr mehr
flachig alles absuchen nach Griechen war
einfach
wenn irgendwas wohnen verletzte
menschliche Geduld Boss der Geruch
eigentlich
vom Furkapass 4 bis auf der Hungerberg
hat aber dort oben auch mit diesen
Suchenden keine wirkliche Spur aufnehmen
können und auch keine erfolgreiche Suche
durchführen können wenn ich Körper mit
der Idee vor dass man ein Part I fordere
und das denn der Spur geht
[Musik]
ich bin
ehemaliger Polizist der Kantonspolizei
Neuenburg
seit eineinhalb Jahren wohne ich mit
meiner Frau in Südspanien
habe ich bei der Polizei gearbeitet 15
Jahre davon war ich als Hundeführer
tätig ich habe unter anderem mit Hunden
sogenannten mantrailern gearbeitet die
nach vermissten Menschen suchen
[Musik]
ich erinnere mich wie ich damals ins
Wallis gerufen wurde wegen einer
vermissten Frau
sollte ich mich erinnern kann war die
Frau ungefähr 60 Jahre alt es war ein
deutsches Ehepaar
ja der Hund ist denn vor Ort geflogen
wurde und dann hätten dem Hund
zum schmecken
ich ging ins Zimmer der Vermissten um
den Geruch von ihr zu holen für den Hund
das ist sehr wichtig
es muss ein reiner Geruch sein meist ist
es ein Kleidungsstück dass man verwendet
es kann aber auch ein Schmuckstück oder
gar eine Zahnbürste sein
dann wurden wir mit dem Helikopter ins
Gebiet geflogen an den Ort wo sich der
Mann und die Frau getrennt hatten dort
sollte der Hund nach der Frau suchen
und da in dem Gebiet wo man sich
trennten
Hund
leider nicht los
sie blieb in einem Umkreis von 200
Metern es passierte nichts
das war schwierig für mich denn ich
verstand überhaupt nicht warum sie nicht
loszog
ich kann es mir bis heute nicht erklären
mit dem Hund auf der Furkapass war die
gestartet sind
Postauto gestiegen war dort wollte ich
einen zweiten Versuch starten
der Hund hat sofort angeschlagen denn
nicht der erlaubt wäre
der Direktor der ist direkt losgezogen
in die Richtung wo das Paar die
Wanderung begonnen hatte
der Hundeführer
der Hundeführer das ganz ganz selten
dass ein Hund so eindeutig eine Anzeige
gibt der Hund hat eigentlich unten und
dann ist der Hund noch circa zwei
zweieinhalb Kilometer gelaufen und ich
direkt ob zum Mercedes
sucht das kann verschiedene Gründe haben
bei meiner Hündin zum Beispiel war es so
dass sie nur den Geruch finden konnte
den man ihr gegeben hat
das heißt ist die Person verstorben kann
sie diesen Geruch schon nicht mehr
finden denn der Geruch eines Menschen
verändert sich schon einige Minuten nach
dem Tod das heißt einen Kadaver konnte
meine Hündin nicht finden
Hund kennt wird der Sage zu Ihnen ins
prozahnt ist die Frau bis zu dem See wo
einfach der Hund den Spur verloren hat
ich kann nicht sagen warum der Hund da
aufgehört hat zu suchen das frage ich
mich bis heute
wenn man das Gelände sich jetzt vor Ort
anschaut dann ist es so dass an dass man
von dieser Stelle wenn man nicht sehr
genau weiß wo man ist weil man keine
Karte dabei hat weil man sich vielleicht
nicht so wirklich orientieren kann den
Ort gitsch erkennen kann also Häuser
sieht die das Licht abends brennt
intuitiv würde man dorthin sich in diese
Richtung begeben und da wird das ganze
dann eben sehr unwegsam auch für den
Hund schwer noch irgendeine Spur
aufzunehmen und dort vermuten wird dass
sie dort zu Tode gekommen ist
als letztes Mittel haben die
Öffentlichkeit mit ins bezieht
das heißt mir Händen am Samstag nach dem
Verschwinden von der springend gut euch
die Öffentlichkeit über die vermiss
maligen Kenntnis gesetzt in Damen dass
man das halt in regionaler und in
nationaler Medium veröffentlicht
[Musik]
Unterlage oder was auch immer
zu der Polizei und
hat natürlich immer noch nicht wissen
was es gab ich bin auch nichts los wenn
ich deinen Gang und
bin dann mit deiner Herrschaften am
Tisch kochen und
das Gespräch relativ kurz
die Frau ist tot
[Musik]
ja Emotionen
für die Versäumnisse spricht die
Kantonspolizei ihr Bedauern insbesondere
gegenüber den Familienangehörigen aus
also das ist
gezwungen
oder so passiert ist Polizei die Stadt
Zufälle die macht Fehler wichtig ist
aber das ist in Zukunft nicht passiert
[Musik]
aufgrund von der mediamitteilung hat
sich
grauschneiderat Steffi bei mir gemeldet
sie ist
noch dazu
[Musik]
die Frage ob sie versicherungsweg
gegangen
die Frage
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir sind hier hergekommen mein Mann und
meine zwei Söhne die waren
9 und 14 ungefähr und sein Hund war auch
dabei und mein Sohn wollte baden gehen
bist du in Erinnerung habe weil das ist
ja schon neun Jahre her und er hat dann
einen großen Knochen an der
Wasseroberfläche gefunden und hatten
gezeigt guck mal was ich gefunden habe
und dann haben wir einen Knochen in der
Hand und der Hund hat einen Knochen dann
habe ich gedacht oh ist es vielleicht
Menschenknochen und hat mein Mann gesagt
aber das glaubte nicht du liest hast du
nicht zu viele Krimis und so und aber
mir hat es halt einfach keine Ruhe
gelassen habe dann Fotos gemacht
und dann bin ich eben 20er 2 Wochen
später es hat mir keine Ruhe gelassen
mit meinem hundebekannten noch mal
hergekommen und habe ihm das gezeigt
weil ich hatte die da oben hat man sie
ins Gebüsch gelegt die Knochen und er
hat gesagt also für ihn ist das
eindeutigen Oberschenkelknochen hat
gesagt gut dann
einmal als daheim sondern rufe ich die
Polizei an und meldet das mal das
gefunden haben ja
[Musik]
und dann hat sich der bestätigt dass das
wirklich Menschenknochen sind eben von
deiner Mutter und da war ich natürlich
froh dass man es gemeldet hatten
2017 das erste Mal hier gesehen dann
haben wir mit dir treffen und du hast
mir die Stellzeit
es war nicht ganz leicht sie aber das
war glaub ganz schlimm für dich das
erste Mal ist sicher
waren ja ziemlich viel Trainer vergossen
das weiß ich
für mich war klar sie ist gestorben es
waren zwei Knochen und das ein Mensch
ohne Oberschenkelknochen
vielleicht schon leben kann aber dann
wäre er irgendwo im Krankenhaus gewesen
oder so aber nicht dass der angeschwemmt
kommt so also
ja für mich ist die Hoffnung dass sie
vielleicht trotzdem
ich weiß nicht das
[Musik]
aber ja
neben einem menschlichen Knochen wurde
ebenfalls ein Tierknochen aufgefunden
dieser Knochen wurde nach Einstellung
des todesermittlungsverfahrens
vernichtet
[Musik]
es gibt noch eine Karte die meine Mutter
aus dem Urlaub unserer Tochter
geschrieben hat
[Musik]
die Karte kam dann als wir aus der
Schweiz zurück waren war die dann im
Briefkasten da drauf steht lieber
Antonia
viele liebe Grüße aus der Schweiz senden
dir Mama und Papa deine Oma
[Musik]
geschickt am
14.09 das war der Tag
der andere auf der
praktisch auf der Jahrestag sind Familie
wieder hier
[Musik]
sondern das Kreuz aufgestellt haben
denn die
bin ich mit deiner zusammen
beurteilt dass der Hund die Spur im See
verloren hat ob man nicht dass
[Musik]
sehr schwache
das sind alles nur ein abtaste
und Du darfst halt nichts gemacht also
Melodie Frau da drinnen gefunden
[Musik]
irgendwann denkt man dann aus wenn man
im Bett liegt auch mal darüber Nase okay
wie viel Geld haben wir eigentlich heute
schon ausgegeben und wie lange können
wir das noch durchhalten und wenn
natürlich
die Person nicht gefunden wird dann
müsste das dankhöriger bezahlen den
zollkäfer sicherlich in einem vermisst
du voll war die Kantonspolizei Wallis in
Isatz steht entstand für die Polizisten
deutlich über 100.000 Euro gekostet und
dann müssen wir einfach reden das waren
einmal am Punkt
ist das bezahlbar auch ein Grund aber es
war nicht der alleinuntergrund deswegen
haben wir dann in Absprachen beim
Stiefvater an einem bestimmten Punkt
[Musik]
das ist eine verletzte gemeinsame
Adresse wo Gino mit ihrem damaligen
Freund bewohnt hat und
wo man sie nimmt keine weiterverfolge
haben
und Kamera hofft dass Sie weitere
Informationen vor ihm brennt überholen
lieblichen Vater von Marco will
offensichtliche
Vater und später hat
ja also ich habe ja schon abgefunden
damit dass das mit der Vater nicht
findet
[Musik]
ihn veronico ich bin hier seit 28 Jahren
zu Hause
92 in Zürich
Wecker Taxi neben der Winterthur und so
eine Ausgang ich hatte sie kennt
war eine erlebliche Tip oder gibt eine
vorige Kraft von Label oder
die Farbe langsam immer mehr verliebt
und natürlich gefragt ob er den
Vaterschaft die mache und der hat der
Universität gemacht
was
sehr schade für mich sieht weil ich habe
mit dem Mensch sehr gut verstanden sehr
sehr sympathisch gesehen und hätte mir
gewünscht dass es mir aggressiver
Auskunft
von ihrem Mutter an ihre Sohn das hatte
praktisch ihre Mutter
kennengelernt und ich wollte zeigen
dass die die Mutter war wirklich eine
tolle Idee
[Musik]
gemeinsam unterwegs waren saßen wir
häufig im Auto fuhren herum und haben
miteinander geredet
sie hat mir von ihrem Inneren ihren
Träumen erzählt
auch von ihren Schwierigkeiten
Schwierigkeiten ein normales Leben zu
führen das was sie sich eigentlich
gewünscht hat
ich weiß nicht ob Marco eines Tages
seinen Vater finden wird vielleicht ist
das aber auch gar nicht so wichtig
ich kann wiederholen was seine Mutter
sagen würde
es ist nicht wichtig was war wir müssen
nur nach vorne schauen
[Musik]
dass sie dort noch
sich befindet ist für uns
gesetzt
[Musik]
ich vermute nicht
man hätte von der Stelle aus die
furkapasshöhe nicht mehr im Hellen
erreichen können
die zum Beispiel Autostop gemacht und
ist es so irgendwas
speziell weil meine Hündin dort oben auf
dem Berg wo die Frau von ihrem Mann
zuletzt gesehen wurde eine Anzeige hätte
machen müssen
das ist mir von diesem Einsatz bis heute
in Erinnerung geblieben
also ich mag mir nicht vorstellen dass
meine Mutter in ein fremdes Auto
gestiegen ist und mit irgendjemandem
irgendwo hingefahren ist der sie der ihr
was Böses angetan hat mit 100%iger
Sicherheit Harmonie
passiert ist passiert ist und das ist
euch die Ungewissheit war zurückbliebt
mit der Familie und euch mit der Polizei
dass man nie erwarte genau wissen was
ist passiert solange wenn man die Person
nicht gefunden hängt
es ginge mich gut überhaupt nicht gut
mein Stiefvater ist letztes Jahr
verstorben also
elf Jahre danach saß noch genauso aus im
Haus wie in dem Tag als weggefahren sind
Jacke ich nach der Probe Handtasche
alles genauso
eigentlich bis zum Schluss ist ja nicht
drüber weggekommen
[Musik]
spurlos verschwunden heißt es gibt keine
Angaben die helfen könnten die Person zu
finden
[Musik]
ja ich bin nach Hannover zogen Weg der
Liebe und ja wohne jetzt da schaffen da
haben wir jetzt aufgebaut und ja sehr
glücklich
[Musik]
ich schaffe da sein Ufer aus
Altenpfleger
also mit Job ist soweit dass sie logisch
dass die Leute betreut sind und dass sie
Ablauf geregeltisch von Tag guten Tag
hallo wie geht es ihnen wer so
lala
[Musik]
und möchte natürlich für sie da sind auf
ihrem letzten Weg so zeigen
ja das meine Mutter ist die Chance sehr
lieb das muss sie sicherlich sehen
[Musik]
mit dem Herzen die Wahrheit glauben also
ich denke so lange nicht
hundertprozentigen
[Musik]
solange
machen ganz viele
Vermögen zurück aber solange im Umgang
schreibt
[Musik]
für Polizei ausspannungsfeld aufgrund
von der aktuellen
[Musik]
was ist passiert
[Applaus]
das moin am vermisst du voll wird das im
konkreten Fall xenisch Gott gar nichts
findet vor der Freude wo verschwunden
ist ist eher äußerquelle
[Musik]
immer wieder sofort so wo mir der ist
als im Kopf präsent ist
nach wie vor mit diesem vermisst du das
hier aktiv im Fall das Neuigkeiten die
zum vermisst du vollspringen gut dass
man neue Erkenntnisse sein neue
Information
[Musik]
also diese Vorstellung irgendwo zu
liegen Blick aus Matterhorn ist gar
nicht so schlechte Vorstellung
also das haben wir uns einfach so
ausgedacht ist so erzählt und ich kann
mir das schöner vorstellen als irgendwie
unter drei Meter unter der Erde zu
liegen
das ist so die Version die wir uns
zurechtgelegt haben
[Musik]
Dossiers zu Langzeit vermissten Personen
werden bei vielen polizeikurs in der
Abteilung Leib und Leben archiviert
in der Regel werden sie zwischen 50 bis
100 Jahren aufbewahrt dann werden sie
gelöscht
[Musik]